you did Sulu shot Zulu and you were
naked in that I was curious like that is
always something I felt like I would
draw the line at being naked is that the
kind of thing you get used to when
you're naked I'll tell you what's
interesting is when you open the scripts
and somebody says then you read in the
first scene for the characters Brian
gets outta bed naked with a gun and
walks down to the kitchen to you know
apprehend an intruder I hit the gym that
was the first thing I did hit a gym in a
big way right but being on set naked is
kind of far it's kind of a funny thing
because you think that you imagine that
you're gonna be really embarrassed you
know you think I'm gonna be super
embarrassed I'm walking around with my
jangles hanging out but that's never
called them jangle a jingle jangle
Dunham's it was time to figure out what
to call it a Christmasy phim when you
say it's really Christmassy right so but
literally it was the funniest thing
because they're all you know suddenly
like it's like it's supposed to be a
closed set and yet my dialect coach this
wonderful woman is is is sitting at the
monitor I'm like babe I get out of bed I
don't say anything [ __ ] never know you
might decide you want to say a few words
I get out of bed I won't make it to the
out so that's it you know just like only
people are showing up and hanging out I
feel like and then you sort of brush up
past these sort of macho really macho
South African guys I mean you think
Americans are macho and then you see
yourself African dude they like
epitomize macho machismo yeah and he
said excuse me just coming through here
you know what I mean just brushing past
and they're like but they're rugby
players they've got it going on but it
is kind of like it's like a slightly
awkward moment you don't mean it's well
they're naked all they shower together
Michelle yeah they're they're like
athletes that are here they're naked
constantly take it all the time
you